[Musique]
c'est rigolo c'est rigolo c'est rigolo
c'est rigolo c'est rigolo
brigitte c'est un tas merveilleux
instrument de musique
il ya quantité de corps très souple très
sensible et c'est formidable parce que
je peux toujours savoir exactement à
quel endroit je dois faire une toute
petite pression et un réaction
correspond toujours à ce que je demande
c'est formidable c'est mary
[Musique]
mais ta main sur le grillage voilà voilà
c'est à moi cette jambe jeu là dedans
gelées blanches et mieux mieux comme ça
la lie sur la pointe donc le cas c'est
que ça fait des voix ce maillot c'est
pas bon le choix de vous moi parce que
sans cet état physique j'en sais pas
pour remettre la charrue haye la vache
tout ce que ça fait un mal aujourd'hui
les terribles notamment mano j'y ai
passé je suis vieille nîmois 1 je crois
que c'est mieux comme ça à cora comme
savoir aussi que la fissure de travail
ou pour à genoux carrément attention
maintenant à temps ou pas parce que j'ai
mal non oublie cela voilà vous voyez
vous
position position inconfortable ça
m'arrange pas fort
alors moteur
[Musique]